في غضون ذلك قالت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت 13
طائره مسيرا انتحاريه هاجمت البلاد من
الشمال والجنوب الشرقي فيما افاد مراسل
الجزيره ان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
تصدت لاهداف في سماء العاصمه كما حذرت
السلطات السكان من خطر جوي في مناطق شمالي
وجنوبي اوكرانيا وكانت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه قالت ان هجوما بطائرات مسيره
استهدف مدنا اوكرانيا من بينها كييف وطلبت
السكان بالبقاء في مناطق امنه وعاد بتجاهل
صفارات الانذار
كما قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه نفذت سبع غارات جويه وشنت
اكثر من خمسه عشر هجوما على مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه شرقيه
اوكرانيا وجنوبها وذكرت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه في بيان ان دفاعاتها صدت واحدا
واربعين هجوما للقوات الروسيه في عده
اتجاهات واشارت الى ان القوات الروسيه
واصلت هجومها على مدينه بخموت وان السلاح
الجو الاوكراني شنت 9 غارات على مناطق
تمركز الافراد والمعدات العسكريه الروسيه
الينا من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين
نادرغامي ومن كييف مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسحوق مسعود مرحبا بكما وابدا معك حسان
كنا في مطلعي الملف نتحدث عن المعدات
المركبات
العسكريه التي تلقتها اوكرانيا واعلان
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني عن هذا الدعم
الاوروبي وحتى الامريكيه الجديد اجمل لنا
كان قد اعلن عن وصول عدد من الاليات
والمدرعات الغربيه الى اوكرانيا
وقام بجوله بنفسه
بدبابه من طراز تشالنجر 2 البريطانيه وقال
انه يشكر الشركاء الذين قاموا بتقديم هذا
الدعم المهم لاوكرانيا ووعد بان تتوجه هذه
الاليات قريبا الى خطوط المعارك في الخطوط
الاماميه واكد ان هذه المدرعات ستنفذ
وستقوم بعمل مذهل على حد وصفه هذه
التصريحات اتت صبيحه هذا اليوم ولكن خلال
الليل كان هناك قصف على منطقه
بطائرات مسيره وكان هجوم كان هناك هجوم
موسع على عدد من المناطق الاوكرانيه بعدد
من الطائرات المسيره كذلك قالت
الجويه انها اسقطت 13 منها ونحن الان هنا
في منطقه
في هذه المنطقه الغربيه لكييف حيث نقف على
حطام جزء من هذه الطائره نستطيع ان نشاهد
هنا جزء من الطائره المسيره تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها طائره من طراز شاهد هذه
هي
بقايا حطام هذه الطائره محمد كما تشاهد
ربما هذا جزء من الجناح وهذا ايضا اجزاء
من الحطام هذه الطائره قامت
بضرر على عدد من المواقع من بين هذه
المواقع هنا هذا المجمع كما تشاهدون خلفي
الذي يتم العمل الان على اصلاحه من الداخل
وهنا تظهر بعض اثار
قصف الذي قامت به هذه المسيره وهي من بين
عدد كبير من المسيرات اطلق باتجاه
اوكرانيا تقول القوات قويه انه اطلق من
اتجاهين مختلفين بدايه من منطقه الواقعه
عند الحدود الشماليه لاوكرانيا
وكذلك ايضا من بحر ازوف من الجنوب الشرقي
لاوكرانيا هذه
المسيرات ايضا توجهت نحو منطقه الدينافر
تقول القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها
استطاعت ان تتصدى لهذه المسيرات وان
تسقطها هذه التصريحات ايضا اتت في سياق
ايضا الاعلان عن ان القوات الروسيه قامت
بقصف خرسون بقنابله موجهه هذه القنابل من
طراز كاب 500 وهي قنابل شديده الانفجار
تحمل عددا كبيرا او كميه كبيره من
المتفجرات وتطلق من مسافه بعيده اطلقت من
طائرات من طراز سوخوي 35 باتجاه منطقه
خرسون هذه التطورات الميد انيه هنا
بالتوازي مع وصول هذا الدعم الذي تحدثناه
الى اوكرانيا
المتابعه في موسكو لتلقي كييف لهذه
المعدات القتاليه الجديده خاصه وتزامن ذلك
مع هذه التقارير البريطانيه التي تشكك في
قدره القوات الروسيه على التقدم في
لم يصدر في الحقيقه اي رده فعل او اي موقف
من قبل موسكو على تلقي الوصول هذه المعدات
العسكريه الغربيه الى اوكرانيا لكن روسيا
لطالما كانت تتوعد الدول التي تقدم هذه
المساعدات على انها بهذه الخطوات فانها
تنخرط اكثر في هذا الصراع الدائر في
اوكرانيا اضافه الى انها تعتبر بان كل هذه
الاسلحه لن تغير شيئا من خطط موسكو لتحقيق
تلك الاهداف التي رسمتها منذ بدايه ما
تطلق عليه روسيا العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
في اوكرانيا اضافه الى انها تشير بانها
تبعد اي
مفاوضات من اجل التوصل الى حل سياسي
وتطيل أمد هذه
الازمه طبعا وفقه النظره الروسيه بالنسبه
للتصريحات الغربيه بخصوص عجز موسكو بين
قوسين عن تحقيق تقدم كبير فكل هذه التصري
كانت تواجه هنا بروسيا في روسيا بنوع من
عدم الاهتمام لماذا لان روسيا منذ بدايه
عمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا لم تضع اي
مواعيد زمنيه لنقل
لتحقيق اي تقدم او اي سيطر على اي مدينه
على سبيل المثال وكانت تقول بان عمليه
العسكريه تسير وفق
التطورات الاوضاع سواء في اوكرانيا او حول
اوكرانيا وتؤكد في المقابل على انها تسيطر
على
نحو 95% من مقاطعه لوغانسك نتحدث عن نحو
60% او 65% من مقاطعه دونيتسك نفس تقريبا
النسبه في مقاطعه زابروجيا واكثر من 70%
من مقاطعه خرسون لكن التصريحات الان التي
تصدر هنا في موسكو بشكل
لنقل خلال اليومين الماضيين تتعلق بخطط
روسيا لنشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا سفير روسيا لدى واشنطن انطولي
انطونوف قال بان روسيا بهذه الخطوه
والانتقادات الامريكيه لها
تعبر عن ازدواجيه في السياسه الامريكيه
وان واشنطن هي التي دفعت الامور بهذا
الاتجاه باعتبار انها انسحبت من عدد كبير
من
الاتفاقيات التي كانت تؤسس للاستقرار
الاستراتيجي في العالم
شكرا جزيلا لكم